[MUSIC - "SUMMERTIME"
FROM PORGY AND BESS]
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
That was beautiful.
That was Sumayya Ali and David
Hughey, performing "Summertime"
from the Tony Award
winning musical,
"The Gershwins' Porgy and Bess."
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
We are so lucky to
have the wonderful cast
and a few creative members of
this production here at Google.
I would like to welcome
Suzan-Lori Parks,
the musical book adapter, and
the first African-American
woman to win the
Pulitzer Prize in Drama.
[APPLAUSE]
We also have Diane Paulus,
the show's Tony Award
winning director.
[APPLAUSE]
And Michael Strunsky, trustee
of the Ira and Leonore Gershwin
estate, and nephew
of Ira Gershwin.
[APPLAUSE]
Let's start with
you, Suzan-Lori.
For those who might
not know, can you
please tell us what the story of
"Porgy and Bess" is all about?
SUZAN-LORI PARKS: Yes. "Porgy
and Bess" is a love story.
It's set in Catfish
Row, which is
a neighborhood in
South Carolina.
Now, the main action
concerns a man named Porgy.
And he was born disabled.
And because he was
born with a disability,
he actually believes that God
has made him to be lonely,
without love.
And of course, he's wrong.
Because into his life
comes love in the form
of a woman named Bess.
And "Porgy and Bess" is
also about the community
of Catfish Row.
And you get to meet the good
folks and the bad folks,
the church going ladies
and the scallywag men.
You get to see them
survive a hurricane.
BTW, Bess happens
to be also involved
with a guy called Crown.
And so you get a little bit
of a love triangle going on
in there.
DIANE PAULUS: Lots of drama.
SUZAN-LORI PARKS: Lots of drama.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
And Diane, this is a
great American masterpiece
with a significant history.
Can you tell us a little
bit more about that history?
DIANE PAULUS: Yes.
This piece is a great
American masterwork.
And it started as
a novel in 1925
called "Porgy," written
by DuBose Heyward.
It later became a play that
DuBose's wife Dorothy basically
wrote.
She encouraged her husband
to turn it into a play.
They eventually
co-wrote it together.
It premiered on
Broadway in 1927.
George Gershwin was looking
for a subject matter
to write his great
American folk opera.
He famously read the novel
of "Porgy" in one sitting.
Wrote George Gershwin
a letter and said,
I want to turn
this into an opera.
At the time, George Gershwin
said, oh, it's a play.
It's having a
success on Broadway.
So George patiently waited.
And eventually, he
wrote it in 1935.
He brought in his
brother, Ira Gershwin,
who worked on the libretto and
the lyrics with DuBose Heyward.
It premiered in Boston,
1935, then went to Broadway.
So this piece actually
began on Broadway
in the musical theater stage.
There's an incredible piece of
history that I want to mention.
In 1936, the original cast
goes on a very short tour.
They go to Washington, DC.
And they play at the
National Theatre.
And of course, when they arrive,
the theater is segregated.
So the original Porgy,
named Todd Duncan,
said, well, this is a problem.
We're not going to perform this
if this theater is segregated.
And the producers at
the National Theatre
said, well, that's
the way it is.
He said, no, no, no.
You don't understand.
We're not going to perform.
So the producers said, we
have a solution-- Wednesdays
and Saturday matinees
for black people.
And Todd Duncan said,
not good enough.
And Anne Brown, who was the
original Bess, 19-year-old out
of the Juilliard School,
had never acted in her life.
George plucked her
out of Juilliard,
took her into the show.
She stood by Todd Duncan's side.
Then the producers
at the National
said, all right, we've
got another solution--
the second half of the upper
balcony, for every performance,
for black people.
And Todd Duncan and Anne
Brown, and at this point,
the whole cast said,
still not good enough.
They got a little nervous.
The producers, the cast
was being threatened
to be fined for
breaching their contract.
They wouldn't relent.
And in March of 1936,
the National Theatre
is desegregated for the
first time in its history,
thanks to this production.
So yes--
[APPLAUSE]
To me, that is why
I do the theater.
It's not just what's
happening now.
It's the history we come from,
and the fact that this work has
had this long history
through the 20th century,
onwards into the '50s,
with a production that
tours Europe with
Leontyne Price,
William Warfield, Cab Calloway.
The young Maya Angelou was
a dancer in the chorus.
Becomes a movie in 1959
with Sidney Poitier,
Sammy Davis, Jr., eventually
touring opera houses
all over the world.
And then the great gift
of this production,
to have incredible, contemporary
artists like Suzan-Lori
Parks, Diedre Murray, our
choreographer, Ron Brown,
and this phenomenal cast
that you'll meet today,
who are bringing their
own humanity, their story,
their integrity to
add another chapter
to this incredible history.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
And Michael, as the
nephew of Ira Gershwin,
I'm sure you've seen
hundreds of productions
of "Porgy and Bess."
So tell us, what's different
about this Broadway production?
MICHAEL STRUNSKY: Well,
Diane has told you
all about the opera, the
development of the opera,
starting in 1935.
Well, the family
has come to realize
that opera is a kind
of specialized taste.
And "Porgy and Bess" has
such a wonderful universality
that we wanted to find
a team and put together
a team that could bring "Porgy
and Bess" back as a Broadway
musical.
And we picked this
lady here on my left.
And what you're going to see and
what you're going to hear today
is much more of the
Broadway musical version
than the opera version.
The Broadway musical
version is accessible.
It has a tighter dramatic
structure than the opera.
Yes, it doesn't have the highs
and lows of opera performance.
But at the same
time, we have come
to feel that this
is a gift that we
hope the country and the
world will appreciate,
that they can come
and see it in a more
understandable and viable way.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
And Diane, so this was
a musical on Broadway
with a lot of incredible
dancing and choreography.
Could you tell us about how
that works into the show?
DIANE PAULUS: Yes.
We have a great choreographer
named Ron Brown.
And I think another
difference, often
when this is done in
a big opera house,
you have a separate
group of dancers
who are doing the dancing.
But in this production,
we have a tight ensemble.
Everybody is doing everything.
They are singing.
They are acting.
And they are dancing.
And Ron's approach was, I think,
similar to all of our work
on the show, was to really
build authentic expression.
That it's not a
Broadway musical,
here we go, five, six,
seven, eight, jazz hands.
This is about character and
history and people's soul
searching existence.
And that was my quest
in the production.
And it went everything,
for how we cast the show,
how we did the costumes,
and how they move on stage.
Every movement has meaning.
And it's connected.
SUZAN-LORI PARKS:
Can I just say,
we won't see the dances
today, but the dancing
is absolutely amazing.
And I've seen the
show many, many times.
I still cannot believe you
guys are dancing like you do
on stage at the Golden Gate,
and singing brilliantly,
and acting at the same time.
I'm amazed.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: And
finally, this version
of "The Gershwins'
Porgy and Bess"
has had an exciting
journey-- the world premiere
at the American Repertory
Theater at Harvard University,
followed by the Broadway
revival that won the 2012 Tony
Award for Best Musical
Revival, pretty awesome.
And so it won the Tony.
So what is most exciting
out of all this?
What is most exciting about
taking this production
across the country?
DIANE PAULUS: Well, first of
all, making theater is hard,
like everything.
And it takes time.
And we have been on a journey
for years, building this show.
And it's like making a painting.
You just get to go in there
and deepen it and detail it
and rediscover it.
And here we are in 2013.
The world's changed.
We can kind of feel the show in
a new way with new performers.
I think this tour, taking
the show out across America,
is, to me, sort of the
pinnacle of this journey.
Because this is an
American masterwork
that belongs to
American audiences
all across the country.
I mean, it was great.
We did it up at Harvard.
Great we did it on Broadway.
But every single person in every
little hometown across America
should be able to see
this show and say, yes, I
understand the story.
I relate to this struggle,
to this love, and to know it.
Not just people
who know the opera,
but for young people,
that's what's touched me,
is that a young generation can
now say, George Gershwin, wow.
He's good.
And those lyrics, Ira and
DuBose, those are pretty good.
And you know what?
That's our American
cultural history
that we need to educate
and give to people so they
can own it and be proud of it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Great.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
So I'd now like to welcome
Nathaniel Stampley and Alicia
Hall Moran, who play Porgy and
Bess, to perform "Bess, You
Is My Woman Now."
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "BESS, YOU
IS MY WOMAN NOW"]
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
That was so beautiful.
That was so great.
Thank you.
So you guys play Porgy and Bess.
Can you tell us, who are the
characters of Porgy and Bess?
NATHANIEL STAMPLEY:
Well, Porgy and Bess
are two people that probably
wouldn't normally be together.
And through the course of
the show and this story,
some extraordinary events
happen that bring them together.
And they truly are each
other's true loves.
And so once they're together,
their lives completely change.
They become really
different people.
And so it's wonderful to take
this journey every single night
with Alicia.
ALICIA HALL MORAN:
And Suzan-Lori Parks
helped encourage us to
understand these characters as
essential as Romeo and
Juliet, Tristan and Isolde.
These are two Americans
in love, in English.
[LAUGHTER]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
And how did you
guys work to develop
both your individual characters
and their relationship?
ALICIA HALL MORAN:
Bess is a fiery woman
who often finds herself
on the outside of things.
And I don't have any
difficulty understanding
that point of view.
[LAUGHTER]
I had a really
lovely upbringing.
So I think that for
me, all of the work
has been in understanding
kind of that emotional
disenfranchisement,
and really trying
to be more honest to
the humanity of it,
to resist mean mugging, to
resist feeling that there's
something dirty about being
unqualified for a moment.
Because it could just
be the next moment where
you get that qualification.
So it's been a real
journey for me.
But Porgy's has
been also physical.
And I think it would be amazing
if he talked about that role.
It's really difficult.
NATHANIEL STAMPLEY: I
think at the core of Porgy,
in playing this
role, I mean, it's
one of the greatest
roles ever written.
And so it's just humbling,
and honored to be on the stage
and play this role that William
Warfield and Todd Duncan, Simon
Estes, I mean, these
are incredible artists
that have played this
role, Norm Lewis.
And so it's exciting
to be in this role,
and to present it
in a way that is
very accessible to
American audiences.
And it's an honor.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Great, thank you.
And what has it
been like to be part
of the ART production at
Harvard and the Broadway
production, and now the tour?
NATHANIEL STAMPLEY:
It's incredible.
I mean, we've been,
both Alicia and I,
we've been there since Day
One at the workshop, and then
the production at the ART,
which was truly amazing.
Those first audiences, they
taught us a lot about the show.
And I think we learned a lot.
And then we came to New
York, had an incredible run.
And we've got a
Tony to prove it.
And now, we get a chance
to travel the country,
just sharing this
incredible masterpiece
that Diane was talking about.
I think the most exciting
part about this production
is that we're going to
bring younger audiences.
And we're going to introduce
this piece to them.
Whereas people that are a
little bit older than us,
"Porgy and Bess"
means a lot to them.
But for a lot of
younger audiences,
they don't understand
what "Porgy and Bess" is.
Is it Por-gee?
Is it this, that?
And so we're here to sort of
spread the gospel of Gershwin.
So it's wonderful.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you, thank you.
And now, I'd like to invite a
few more people up on stage.
We want to welcome
back Sumayya Ali, who
plays Clara, David
Hughey, who plays Jake.
I'd also like to
introduce Kingsley Leggs.
He plays Sporting Life,
and Alvin Crawford,
who plays Crown, up to
join Alicia and Nathaniel.
[APPLAUSE]
So Sumayya and David, what
is it like starting off
the show with such an iconic
number as "Summertime"?
SUMAYYA ALI: Well, no pressure.
It's only been recorded
over 30,000 times,
more than any other
Broadway song ever.
But at the root, it's
a beautiful lullaby
that parents are
singing to their child.
And I think it represents
all the promise
and hope to come
for Catfish Row.
So it's mostly my
taking myself out of it
and being true to the
story, and just using myself
as an instrument
to give a message.
DAVID HUGHEY: I would
agree with that.
And also, what's
really interesting
about this version is that in
the reworking of the piece,
they really wanted
to establish the love
that Jake and Clara have for
each other and for their child
right at the
beginning of the show.
And so in this
version, Jake gets
to sing along for that reason.
Traditionally in the opera, it's
only Clara who gets to sing it.
And so it's a really
wonderful moment
that we get to share, and
establish that, and sort
of speak that sort of blessing
over our child, if you will.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Great, thank you.
And what does it
mean in the context
of the whole story
of "Porgy and Bess"?
SUMAYYA ALI: Oh, wow.
It means a couple of things.
First of all, I think
it's establishing
the setting of Catfish Row.
I'm talking about, everyone
knows it's summertime
automatically.
[LAUGHTER]
They know the cotton's
high, living's easy.
So I think it's a great
way to not only show
the love and magic
of this community,
but also just set everything
up, to just reel them
in for the adventure
to come, I think.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you, thank you.
Alvin, hello.
In "Porgy and Bess,"
Crown is the antagonist.
But his relationship with Bess
isn't fully straightforward.
What do you think
draws Bess to Crown?
And does Crown have any
redeeming qualities?
ALVIN CRAWFORD: Yes, Crown
does have redeeming qualities.
But I think Crown is
misunderstood, I think.
He loves Bess in his own way.
But one thing I
would love to say
is that we all know that
person in the community who
is that guy.
And we also know that couple
that shouldn't be together.
And that is Crown and Bess.
Because they have that
toxic relationship,
that they don't feed
each other well.
As Nate was saying earlier,
they are good together.
But Crown and Bess are not.
But for whatever reason,
that toxic, drug induced haze
and love is why
they're together.
But I would also say one of the
redeeming qualities about Crown
is that he's the guy that goes
to rescue Clara in the storm.
So he also has a
place in Catfish Row.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
Kingsley, hi.
Tell us, who is Sporting Life?
KINGLSEY LEGGS: Sporting Life
is a snake and a scoundrel.
I always joke backstage,
because I have so many props,
that I have like pockets
full of good times.
I've got playing cards
and money and dice
and hooch and happy dust.
So he brings the
party to Catfish Row.
But he's also directly
responsible for Bess's
downfall.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yeah, and can
you tell a little bit more
about how he influences
that narrative?
KINGLSEY LEGGS:
Well, he instigates
a lot of the tragedy
that happens.
He's right at the centerpiece
of it, making it happen.
Because he has his own
goal and his own objective.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
OK, and now we're going
to have another big hit
from the incredible score.
Kingsley Leggs and
cast will perform
"It Ain't Necessarily So."
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - "IT AIN'T
NECESSARILY SO"]
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you guys.
That song is so much fun.
And the way you guys perform
it, it's just amazing.
Thank you.
And now, we'd like to take a
few questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Just
wondering how you go
through the cycle of emotion.
I imagine it's got to
be really draining.
The story is so
deep and powerful,
how that cycle plays out
on a night to night basis,
how those emotions get
renewed, and how you really
deliver the message with
such heart every time.
KINGLSEY LEGGS: I love being in
shows that are really dramatic
and have this kind of content.
But I was just talking
with Suzan-Lori earlier,
before we started this,
that this, I don't know.
There's just something very
special about this show.
Even watching them
sing that number today,
waiting over there,
I started crying.
I was like, you've got
to get yourself together.
There's such humanity
in this piece
that it's just such a joy to
tell this story every night.
I have to remove
myself sometimes
from the rest of the
piece because of what
I have to do in the
piece, to keep it
all in perspective
and compartmentalized.
But I think part of it is just
the joy of telling the story,
and because these people have
been such incredible stewards
of this piece and the
story and what we're doing.
You just want to give it truth.
You want to give it
all that you have.
And you want it to reach the
person in the top, in the back.
So it's just wonderful
to play every night.
NATHANIEL STAMPLEY:
I'll chime in, also.
With this particular
production, we
don't have the trappings of
really huge sets and a really
large cast.
So the story is
in the forefront.
And so that demands a
certain level of commitment
every single second
you're on the stage.
So there's nowhere to
hide, first of all.
And secondly, as you
can sort of sense today,
we are truly a community
on and off stage.
And so that helps.
And also, for me personally
in this role as Porgy,
I try to keep it as
light as I can offstage.
I like to laugh and smile
and save my voice, as well.
So that you're not living in
those really dark and heavy
moments 24/7.
Because that's tough to carry
around with you all the time.
SUMAYYA ALI: I totally have
to decompress and watch
"Everybody Loves Raymond"
or something when I go home.
I do.
You do.
You have to shake it off.
ALICIA HALL MORAN: And also,
I have to say, those of us
coming from the
previous productions,
and also, now this
cast are veterans,
because they had a rehearsal
process in New York
together, shared.
Really knowing the inner tracks
of the ensemble as well as we
do, we understand
the real strength
that Porgy gains is
from the community.
The real strength
that Bess will find
when she's redeemed-- oh,
she messes it up by the end.
But they come for
her, to heal her,
and to give your body weight
to the women in the cast.
Or Sporting Life slithering
all over you, only Mariah
could prevent that.
And he gets rid of her.
So we really
understand that you're
going to get through the
day with the actual actors.
But the characters
are going to make it
through because of
the actual community.
And we represent
a new era of that.
Because we know what
they're pulling.
And it's crazy good.
I love your question.
Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: I'd like to hear a
little more about the process
of adapting the production
to what you call a Broadway
musical version as opposed
to the opera version?
There's the staging, there's
the music, there's the story.
I'd like to hear
more about that.
DIANE PAULUS: I think if the
opera is done uncut, which
sometimes it's done, it clocks
in at well over four hours.
So I think we knew we wanted
to make a version that really
retained the incredible
score, that told the story as
specifically and as
truthfully as we could.
But we wanted to just
like close up on it.
We wanted to make it intimate
and focused and theatrical.
So of course, our production
is like 2 and 1/2 hours.
So you're looking at cuts.
And George and Ira made cuts.
The first night after
it premiered in Boston,
they cut out 45 minutes.
So you're going from guides from
the original authors of options
of things to cut.
And Suzan-Lori and Diedre Murray
and myself and our music team,
our conductor and our
associate, we spent,
I'd say, at least
one year going bar
by bar through
that entire score,
laboriously figuring
out how to make the cut,
how to continue
the musical line.
What is necessary?
What maybe could we take
out to strengthen something,
to make it even more
kind of immediate?
So it was an incredible process,
a careful, careful process.
SUZAN-LORI PARKS: Yeah, maybe
a chunk might have been cut.
And then add a few words here
to make the character arc
stronger, a lot of
basic dramaturgical,
architectural work to track
each of these characters.
Each and every one of
these main characters
has a very, very strong
and definite character arc.
And sometimes, we might
cut a character out,
a minor character, and
replaced him or her
with one of the main
characters to carry that story
line through.
AUDIENCE: "Summertime" got
rearranged a little bit,
to have an extra singer in it.
So was there much of that
kind of change, as well?
DIANE PAULUS:
Definitely, thinking
about how to tell the story.
And I think the point that
Sumayya and David were making,
that this idea-- you know,
people hear "Summertime."
And you kind of
go, oh, that hit.
Or, oh, Fantasia sang that.
So our production's like,
no, no, look at the story.
Look at what the song
means, with Daddy and Mama
standing by.
And there you can see
that daddy and mama
looking over their baby.
So every choice was
driven by the story,
to really intensify the story.
SUZAN-LORI PARKS: I just want
to say an exciting thing.
You see Jake and Clara
singing this wonderful song
to their child at the top.
And then if you know the show
already, or if you've seen it,
or if you might see it, watch
for when it gets reprised.
And that's in the original.
But watch how that
songs gets reprised.
And remember the first time
you heard it in the show,
and the meaning that it takes on
as we travel through the show,
and the other things going on
on stage, especially when we
hear it the last time.
What is going on?
DIANE PAULUS: It's
sung three times.
And the tragic thing is,
those two characters die.
So you start the show.
And if you know the
story, it's almost
like you almost can't watch it.
It's just like, all the
hope in that moment.
But again, as Alicia
was saying, you
see how the community
rises up through it.
It's that uplifting growth
admits terrible adversity
and tragedy.
MICHAEL STRUNSKY:
One thing that's
true about this is
that the emphasis here
has been on story, just as
any good theatrical piece has
to respect story.
And we've taken,
Diane and Suzan-Lori
have taken that as a charge.
And I believe they've solved it
really, really magnificently.
SUZAN-LORI PARKS: I always
like hearing you say that.
[LAUGHTER]
I never get tired of that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I am completely in awe that I'm
in the same room as Suzan-Lori
Parks and Diane Paulus.
Actually, I'm a graduate
of the ART in 2006.
Sadly, I missed you,
because you have
been doing amazing
work there, amazing.
It's so impressive.
And my question is
actually two things.
How is it that you, A, came
upon this play or musical,
that you wanted to revive it.
And two, how is it that you have
created, in many of your works,
somehow found the balance of
artistry and audience appeal
in such a way that you
make-- obviously, audience
keep coming back and loving
everything that you've done.
Where do you find that?
Because it doesn't
seem to me like
you've sacrificed any
artistry in any of the work
that you've done.
DIANE PAULUS: Well, I'll answer
your second question first.
I believe in the audience.
I believe audiences are smart.
They want to be challenged.
They want to feel.
I think it's a very generous
act, an audience, in this day
and age, when we're all so
busy, to come out of our lives
and be live in a room together.
So we have an obligation
to meet that audience.
And that's where I
start as a director.
It's really not about like,
my art, what I want to do.
No, I think, why
tell the story now?
What's the event?
What can we communicate?
Why should an audience bother
to come see "Porgy and Bess"?
That's where I start.
And rather that being
distracting or pandering,
it's actually the catalyst
for me as a director.
And that's the theater.
I mean, when you work
in the theater now,
you really have to think, what
is the theater as a medium?
It is about live transmission.
It can only happen in the
presence of an audience.
Not a lot of other
artistic mediums
are that dependent on the
living, breathing moment.
And I think in our day and age,
to feel present and alive--
I mean, it was a
question of you,
all saying about being in
the moment, that's a gift.
I mean, that's why I
love doing the theater.
It's like, rehearsal,
you're in the moment,
to come into a room.
And that's, I think,
what an audience craves.
You forget the past.
You stop thinking
about the future.
And you are in the
present, emotionally,
psychically with
these characters.
And this is a piece
that allows you
to go deep, as Kingsley said.
So when I was approached by the
Gershwin estates and the DuBose
Heyward estates, would you
be interested in this charge
that Mike said?
We know it exists as an opera.
And it will always
exist as an opera.
But what about
creating a version that
really celebrates
it as a musical?
Would you want to do that?
And what writer would
you like to work with?
That really came
from the estates.
That was a huge sign to
me of the willingness
to really make this feel
relevant to our lives today.
And working with
Suzan-Lori, I was
dying to work with this lady.
Are you kidding?
She's a genius.
And her dramaturgical
mind is so strong.
[APPLAUSE]
This experience
of creating this,
and then, it's about them.
The art of a director is,
I know something about it.
Suzan-Lori, we know
something about it.
But then it transfers
to the cast.
And that's how they get
through every night, I think.
Because they are
telling the story.
They are the keepers of
the torch and the flame.
And they are holding that
much more than us now.
We've given it.
We've raised the baby.
And then the baby has to go
out in the world, in this case,
across America.
AUDIENCE: I know you
mentioned briefly
Leontyne Price and that tour.
And I think you were
referring to the 1955 tour
to the Eastern Bloc.
So I know that was a huge deal.
Because that was the
first American musical
or American opera that came to
USSR and all those countries.
And I know they had a different
message to spread back then.
But I'm wondering, if you
had the opportunity now,
maybe you will,
where would you take
this production in the world?
And what kind of
message would you
want to say now, as
opposed to back then?
MICHAEL STRUNSKY:
Well, I'm not sure
that the message is anything
more than what you see.
The message is there.
It's truth, and what
Suzan-Lori and the rest
of the creative cast believe
that community was like.
And yes, we're open to
taking-- a matter of fact,
we are doing a
production in London
at the outdoor theater
there this coming summer.
SUZAN-LORI PARKS: I
think what's wonderful
about this production is
that while our work on it
was, or my work on
it was dramaturgical
and architectural,
I think what happens
is, in this day
and age, there is
a political component
that we can't escape.
And that is as simple as people
of African descent are people.
We are people.
And I think that is
dovetailed exactly
hand in glove with the
message, if you will,
of the very first production
of "Porgy and Bess."
I think that's what Mr.
Gershwin's and the Heywards
were saying.
I think that's what it said when
we went to the Eastern Bloc.
And that's the beauty
of this country,
that we can say that
about all of us.
We are all in it together.
And when we take that
and we go abroad,
or we go just to various cities
around the United States,
we are all in it together.
Hello.
And when we go abroad
and take that message,
we are all in this together,
that is a very powerful message
for the world, to remember
that it's all of us
together in here.
So it's good stuff.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: One more
question, one last question.
AUDIENCE: I have a question for
Sporting Life, Porgy, and Bess.
Individually, do you think your
characters would have liked
to have seen a sequel
to Porgy and Bess?
And to Michael, do you know if
your Uncle Ira and George, had
he lived, had planned a sequel?
MICHAEL STRUNSKY:
Not that I know of.
And I guess emotionally, I
would very much doubt it.
They had plenty of
other things to do.
[LAUGHTER]
NATHANIEL STAMPLEY: I'll just
say, in this day and age now
of prequels, I'm actually
more interested in that, this
before story.
And the way that this
production is put together,
it really is up to the audience
to decide what happens.
And I think that's where,
as actors and audience,
we're all in the
same room, that's
one point where we
all get together.
You decide.
Everyone walks out of the
theater with different answers.
So at the stage
door, I enjoy to hear
what happens with
Porgy and Bess.
ALICIA HALL MORAN: I
love this question.
Because you're going to hear
our personalities in how
we answer it.
So his idea would
make money with before
and a blockbuster after.
And my idea is kind of that
it's being presented as a fable,
in a sense, in the original,
and in the way it's
been recreated here.
So that just like
Diane said, it's
heartbreaking when the young,
beautiful couple comes out
for "Summertime"
with their baby.
Because you know by the end, and
the harlot is holding the baby.
Man, oh, man, that's
the cycle-- the baby,
the birth, the birth
of something else.
It's going to go well for you,
or it's going to go badly.
You kind of get another
shot at it the next day
in the next show.
So I think we are, each
of us, are everyone.
Not an every man, so much,
specifically in the narrative
structure, but like Aesop's
Fables, there's no before.
There's no after.
It's its own universe.
You're going to be the
dinosaur this time,
and the monkey next
time, that kind of idea.
And I know there's no
dinosaurs in Aesop's.
Don't get all technical with me.
[LAUGHTER]
KINGLSEY LEGGS:
That was awesome.
I agree with Nate.
I think what's extraordinary
about this piece is
that it's not wrapped
up in a bow at the end.
And it allows everyone to have
their own interpretation of,
how does the story end?
How do you think it ends?
How would you like it to end?
And I think that's
wonderful for everyone.
I think probably the dying
question for everyone is,
does he find her in New York?
Does he make it to New York?
Does he find her in New York?
But I really feel that
it's best the way it is.
It's best that we don't know.
I think that goes along with the
message and the spirit of what
the piece is.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And now, the last song
we're going to hear today
is Nathaniel and
the cast singing,
"I Got Plenty of Nothing."
MICHAEL STRUNSKY: You should
know that the next scene is
shortly after Porgy and Bess
get together for the first time.
It's morning.
And I'll let the cast
take it from there.
[MUSIC - "I GOT
PLENTY OF NOTHING"]
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Ladies and gentlemen,
the cast of "Porgy and Bess."
Another round of applause.
Thank you for joining
us here at Google.
And thank you guys for
joining us, as well.
And thank you for coming.